hello everyone um
welcome um I want to talk to you today
about um proofs and programs as you can
see and I I think I want first to say
thank you to Zan and for inviting me and
and also to uh to Alex for organizing
this I think this conference is a very
interesting and very different
conference from the ones that I normally
speak at
um must forget mustn't forget the the
clicker and um before before kind of
talking more about what about my proofs
and programs I wanted to talk to you a
little bit about what the topos
Institute is because the topos Institute
is a very new kind of a place it is a
startup but it's a not for-profit
startup up so it's a research institute
where we actually shape technolog for
the public benefit by advancing Sciences
of connection and
integration and this is kind of cool
right because you know um uh like most
of you here I've been working silic in
Tech actually in Silicon Valley for 24
years
and and there aren't much I mean there's
Academia and we have lots of lots lots
of lovely talks yesterday kind of more
academic and some uh lots of very
exciting stuff in industry but things
that stay in the middle between the two
are kind of
rare and um so yeah I was saying I kind
of been in Silicon Valley for 24 years
and I started in park for many years and
then I went to startups and did a a
failed search engine but you know
there's plenty of us around uh then I
worked in Nuance Communications as thean
was saying doing um doing an LP and kind
of trying to use the voice recognition
stuff to do more thinking and in in
Samsung but but uh lately in Samsung but
but then I decided that um I was going
to go back to my roots and and my roots
are very different so my background is
I'm a
mathematician um and um and so I was
kind of very worried to come here and
talk to you guys because I thought well
these guys are not going to understand
me very well because you know as you
know mathematics builds upon it itself
so you know to explain things in
mathematics you actually have to go uh
you have to go doing things over and
over and over again so that you get to
an interesting bit so I kind of decided
that I was going to talk to you today
using stories and philosophical ideas
and I hope you like it um but if you
don't and you want to have the the real
stuff you can always talk to me in
Discord or in slack or send me email and
all this kind of stuff and I wanted to
start on the stories with this three
guys on top there because you know
mathematicians have this funny habits of
talking about their memic family so that
guy there on the left with nice smile is
my uh supervisor as we say in England or
advisor as you say here and um he um
he's called Martin Highland and he's
considered my academic father and the
second guy there is Robin gji who is who
was his advisor or supervisor and I hope
you all recognize the the guy on the
on the right right because you know I am
kind of I was lucky enough to I'm lucky
enough to be the great granddaughter of
alen shuring and um and that's kind of
quite ex it's quite special right
because you know juring
uh invented computers before there were
machines and we I'm going to discuss
some of his work here on on the proofs
that he did and stuff and later on he
went on to implement the real stuff in
Manchester in the
50s and the guy on the bottom is not
part of the family he is he's goodgo um
um a guy who kind of put some wrenches
in in the systems that we were that
people were trying to do but um but it
that that's very much part of my stories
to you
today so I wanted to start by saying
this business that changing models is
really hard and I mean mental models and
mathematical models and physical models
all of them are very hard to change and
I thought I was going to go through um
three kinds of changes changes of models
that with you kind of starting from the
easiest one to the hardest one and the
first one that I'm going to talk to you
about is revolution in the sky then I
want to talk about revolution in
mathematics then I want to talk to you
about revolution in computation which I
think which the main thing which I think
what you're more interested in and then
because you've been so nice to set sit
through all these revolutions I wanted
to talk to a little bit about the
dialectical construction if you have me
and if Cliff doesn't say that time is
up why do I want to talk to you about
revolution in the sky well first because
you can get very pretty pictures like
that one there and um and also because
when you're thinking about disguise and
the um and how people
conceptualize uh space you know you are
faced with things that are very much on
your day-to-day experience so I don't
want you to think about the guy peering
outside of the Sky Dome I'm thinking
just I just want to you to think about
the sun coming up and the sun coming and
the moon coming up because you know this
is an experiment that everyone
has and and in
1543 Copernicus kind of uh decide kind
of came in with this Theory to try to
change uh this model so um he kind of
had been thinking about it since
1514 and you can read Lots about it in
Wikipedia but uh so in six in 15 14 he
actually had a tease a a a trailer h a
blog post about his theory of
heliocentrism and you know he was going
very much against everyone's um
sensorial experience of seeing the Sun
come from one side and sit up
sat down on the other side and contrary
to you what you might think people
didn't go against him to begin with you
know it took 73 years for the church to
start saying things against Copernicus
Copernicus Theory so and that only
started happening because Galileo galile
came into the story and decided to um to
show people that the Earth really wasn't
the center of the universe and that
mankind wasn't
exactly uh the main creation of God and
stuff like that and in 1615 Galileo
started being
investigated um then people noticed wow
he has based himself on Copernicus so
there's something kind of that we might
have to look at and in 1620 Copernicus
book was corrected I mean cernic
Copernicus was very
um worried about this stuff so he
actually apparently uh only published
his book when he was about to die and
Legend has it that he actually uh wake
up from a coma looked at the last page
of his book and died happy
but that's the that's what they say
right but um he he was very afraid of
what was happening when he kind of moved
the uh from the center of the Universe
like he did so he um he kind of wrote a
book with lots of if and lots of
hypothesis and and instead of talking
about things as if they had happened and
and Galileo was a slightly different and
he started making fun of the people and
stuff like that so the book was
corrected in 1620 um in 16 in
1632 Galileo came with his own book
which was much more
um on your face and the next year he got
under house arrest and and died in House
of rest and only in
1835 both both of the books were gotten
out of the index the Inquisition index
because
between 1543 and 1835 there were
prohibit uh by The Authority by the
authorities now so that was uh
Revolution that took a long time right
300 years or perhaps even a bit
more now in mathematics we also had a
revolution and that's kind of harder to
see because
um people don't really
realize what is happening in mathematics
by and large and you you know if you
want to read more and that's just an
intermission uh between the two things
that I wanted to talk to you about so
you know in um 200 12 U Frank Quin a
important mathematician wrote this paper
called a revolution in mathematics uh
what really happened a century ago and
why it matters today and I recommend you
guys kind of going and checking it out
um but the main point is that the bulk
of mathematics that we got today was
crystallized in the last years of the
19th century First Years of the 20th
century and the shock is still being
felt oops too fast and um one
more and the thing about that a
revolution in mathematics is that
um that it hasn't kind of come through
totally yet right you know if you come
to a p and you say to someone that
you're a mathematician they look at you
and say oh that's funny I didn't think
that anyone could do research in
mathematics I thought it all all had
been done a long time ago so you know
people haven't really cut on to the fact
that mathematics is a living subject as
living as as as Computing and everything
is happening all the time and we're
building new mathematics every single
day and um they also don't realize that
mathematics is not about numbers it's
about structures connections and
especially
proofs and the other thing that that
people don't realize is that uh I'm kind
of using algebra here not in the sense
that you normally have when you're
thinking of algebra in eighth grade or
anything like that you know there's a
completely different algebra that has to
do with some of the stuff that we heard
yesterday so you know people were
talking about luses and and groups and
monoids and and stuff like that and um
and then you know what we have at the
moment is that the mathematics that we
have kind of the algebra in this new new
sense of algebra and the proofs in this
new sense of of of doing new mathematics
this is all kind of happened this week
this Century this week this century and
um and you know the Revolution was so
complete that it happens everywhere if
you take any undergrad in mathematics
nowadays he thinks that mathematics is
about proofs and
structures uh and if you go anywhere in
the world and try to go to the to a m
the department they they don't think
that they can do mathematics if they're
not doing proofs so the revolution is
completed in some ways and not completed
in
others but of course people here are
much more interested in Revolution in
computation and um the one that I mean
is actually the K Howard correspondence
so proofs as types propositions as types
and this is something that's been going
on for quite a while right from 1908
to now and we are still not quite there
yet and I mean what is the koud
correspondence you know in papers we
love 2015 you had a beautiful uh talk by
Phil wler exactly about that and the the
the video is up on YouTube everyone can
go and and and watch it so you know why
am I here trying to tell a different
different a different story about the
same subject well the reason I'm here
trying to talk to you about that is
because as I say this stuff is not done
you know it's very hard to see change
while you you are in the middle of it
while things are happening still and the
traditional kry how which uh connects
intuitionistic propositional logic
simply type Lambda calculus in cartisian
close categories is um it's been in
place for a relatively long time from
since the 60s 68
69 but but that's only
one uh one addition of it one version of
it and what I'm trying to tell to sell
to you today is actually um the fact
that you can have several different kard
correspondences the saying that you
still need you have is the connection
the connections between um Logics and
that's another thing that people don't
understand if you say uh I'm a logician
I deal with different Logics they look
what AR isn't logic a single thing isn't
that either you're logical logical and
that's it and it's not and that I think
you all know that um that we have
different logical systems for different
um different applications different uses
um so this is the traditional K Howard
and and how this came about why I'm
talking about Revolutions in computation
and kind of talking about something that
happened in the
60s and here I'm actually kind of very
happy that yesterday we had so so many
wonderful talks about similar stuff
right because everyone should know by
now that um the K how is a fundamental
result connecting Logics programming
languages and
categories and um and that the original
K how ties logic and type
Theory and you know here is where I
depart from F wler stuff because um f
kind of talked very much about type
theories that is programming language
when you implement them and um and
Logics different kinds of Logics but I
want to put you I I want you to make
sure that you see a third side of the
career C I want you to make sure that
you see the left side there where we
have B representing uh mathematics
proofs and in in category Theory and I
wanted you to make sure and I wanted to
make sure that you know you if you want
to understand the stuff properly if you
want to make sure that you can see why
the fat arrows there really exist then
you know you have to do the hard work
I'm not going to kind of do the hard
work for you right now I'm just going to
try to show you uh where you need to go
and look so that you can
see why having this fat arrows is
important so let's see um so the each
one of the arrows connects two different
fields and you can uh look again on the
on the YouTube um video of few waterers
oops too much but why this this thing
kind of came about when it
did and the reason is because
mathematics was in turmoil um at the
beginning of the last century in 1906
buern Russell came up with his famous
Russell Paradox and people realized that
even if you are careful while you
thinking and even if you were trying to
formalize your thoughts thoughts and
stuff you still could get into
paradoxes and Hilbert the guy with this
hat came up and said well we need to
kind of formalize things and we need to
make sure that we can prove some of the
special um some special properties of
all of
mathematics he actually wanted to base
everything on fistic methods and his
first most important goal was to prove
consistency of arithmatic so you know
things like uh dividing sharing bills in
bars and stuff like that adding
subtraction dividing and stuff should
work the way we expect it to
work and hbert had had this wish list
and I had taken off this slide before
because I thought you guys wouldn't like
to hear about extra um extra properties
like consistency and completeness and
conservativeness and
decidability but you know you know I
think May did a wonderful job yesterday
telling us how we need consistency just
to kind of uh run tournaments all over
the
world and um and how you actually need
completeness uh otherwise you cannot
um prove that you actually have the
correct players for for your games and
she didn't use the word conservativity
she used monotonicity but it's a similar
sort of idea
so Hilbert wanted mathematics to satisfy
all these four properties and I'm sure
you agree with me that they are sensible
properties that we want our systems to
satisfy these things as much as possible
right because we also want our systems
to do things for
us so GTO the guy that I put it in the
first in the together in the same slide
as the family slide uh was the guy who
destroyed the idea of hbert program with
his incompleteness terms and I'm not
going to talk to you about
incompleteness STS because there's lots
of people kind of who like to talk about
that and I I'm not particularly fond of
but
um GTO really proved that hbert program
is impossible as in if you interpret it
in the most direct way but of course
logicians uh did not kind of go to sleep
and decided that things could not be uh
proved cons consistent they they just
decided to there are ways around that
and there's things that we can do one of
the things that we can do is we can use
more powerful methods and we're going to
see that in a minute but the other thing
that you can do is that you can do
something called proof Theory and you
can actually
um where you can actually try to see how
much you can prove with which whichever
methods you can use
and that is what um my wartime proofs
are about because in
1934 um geart gensen who was assist an
assistant of of hbert uh came up with
the true systems of describing Logics
that you all kind of used when you use
BNS and and inference rules and and you
semantics of programming languages and
stuff like that so these systems are
called natural deduction and sequent
calculus and they are the main proof
systems used nowadays by everyone and
the same guy did both of them in one
paper in
1934 and we don't talk much about him
because he was a prison of War on the
other side so and died in in prison so
it's a bit of a difficult
story but GTO back to him um he had a
different way of trying to go around the
problems of incompleteness you know he
proved incompleteness he was the guy who
broke up the Hilbert program but he
actually believed in the same things
that we're saying a minute ago he also
wanted to prove consistence of
arithmetic and he had his own way of
proving consistence of
Artic so we can we say sometimes that
that he had a liberalized version of
hbert program and he just want to
justify the systems that we have in
terms of notion
as intuitively clear as possible and you
know that intuition is the stuff that is
been running through my uh Revolution
right um so he came up with a notion of
computable or primitive recursive
functions of finite type and then he
used the dialectica which we'll see in a
minute again um
to to try to go
around um the noo term that he himself
had
created and I've kind of been talking
about what I'm proofs for a long time
now um 20 slides and what about the
programs well the programs we kind of
had lots of interesting things about
them yesterday too in darkg talk right
because
um the fact is that when people started
thinking about Computing as a machine
like activity they they came up with
different Notions of computable or
effective computations so alono Church
came with the Lambda calculus in
1932 and he kind of came up with this
idea that a Lambda term uh H Lambda term
is a machine computable function and
every machine computable function is a
Lambda term and I thought you guys are
going to have to take that on on trust
from me but you don't right because you
know yesterday Doug showed you that you
can take the whole of the C programming
language and kind of translate it into
Lambda calculus completely and you can
go and check it in the web if you want
so yeah kind of I think people do feel
that um machine computable functions are
LDA terms and hasco Curry we also heard
about him yesterday because we also
heard about combinators and combinator
combinatory logic and and that's where
I'm getting the 1908 sort of number
because Sean FCO kind of died very young
too and kind of in 1908 came up with
this idea that you could do all this
stuff with SNK like again Doug showed
yesterday and um and then my favorite
guy touring kind of came up with his own
version and came up with the notion of a
touring machine and explained why this
was what a computable function should be
and then we now have cheses that all
these things are equivalent so you know
it does look like we are actually doing
this business of investigating the
structure of the universe and finding
the structures that are underneath
things now um I kind of was worried that
I I had to that um that you wouldn't
like to see any mathematical symbols I
shouldn't have worried people yesterday
use lots of TOs and gamas and sigmas and
stuff like that but you know I can also
think about traditional logic and you
know guys this is Middle Ages logic
right this rule on the left if I have
that a implies B and I have an A then I
approve a b this is mod ponents the
monks in in kind of in the Middle Ages
were're using it the side the other side
is a little bit more complicated and a
bit more like stuff that you guys like
to do right because it's this idea that
if I assume a and I do a collection of
operations over this a the things that
I'm kind of putting the three dots and
calling it a pi and I then derive a b
any B whatsoever then that is something
like an implication it makes me gives me
an implication a implies B and in 2023 I
can just do K how very easily by adding
terms to it adding lmed terms m n
application of
m2n x a variable of type A M deriving an
M of type B and then getting a LDA
abstraction so that is all very easy
nowadays and as I was saying kind of
Lambda calculus is by all accounts an
Universal programming language but
yesterday again we did see lots of other
things that are a little bit more
complicated than calculus and and pure
functional programming right um we kind
of want to do things like distributed
computing we don't to do parallel
programming and we want to do all sorts
of interesting effects and these these
things are active areas of
research but most of them we are
actually trying to attack using
extensions of the K how correspondence
so you know even locks and unlocking and
unlocking comput threads and stuff like
that we can there are ways of doing
these things using versions of Curry
Howard so we do have a cornucopia of new
Logics and new program constructs based
on the
correspondence
and and that's before you start bringing
in the have Machinery that is category
Theory so I want you to think about I
mean I'm not going to give you
definitions of categories funs and
natural Transformations but I'm going to
remind you that um that the same way was
kind of calling algebra some things that
are that started from solving it simple
simple equations in a e grade and then I
be I made it algebra a name for all of
this stuff well category theor is a
little bit like uh algebra on a
steroids and and the hard bit here when
you kind of try to make this Corr
responden stick is actually um finding
and and it's kind of a it's a little bit
on the small um on the small words there
appropriate right you have to find an
appropriate category an appropriate
appropriate morphism in this category
and appropriate logical Constructors and
all this thing has to satisfy certain
conditions but we can do it and you can
do it for several Logics like
intuitionistic logic system F
polymorphism dependent type Theory
linear logic model Logics classical
Logics and I think you know you can see
that's lots of of the systems that we
that we have been talking yesterday and
today about things like rust and hco and
okamo they're all based on this ideas of
Curry how
correspondence and more more to my point
at the moment we're doing things with um
T improvers and proof assistance so
Isabelle lean all this stuff um is based
on variant of K how
correspondence and I kind of have a few
more pictures here just because of they
are the ones that I worked on personally
so I worked on linear Lambda calculus
and kind of you heard yesterday from
from a mou that kind of it is part of
the what is happening in trust it's a
fine types but they like linear types um
I worked in model uh correspondences and
and we actually use that for all sorts
of interesting stuff like
um like mons and comonads are versions
of model Logics and and and hence we can
use it for all sorts of
effects and even the linguists can use
that uh for Syntax for in things like
the lambc calculus
but and now I kind of I have to see how
I'm doing I'm
getting I'm good good because I wanted
to talk a little bit about something
much more recent than the stuff that I
was describing before which is kind of
beginning of the 2000s so I wanted to
talk a little bit about what um about
that uh trick of guo uh that I started
talking about a minute ago about trying
to prove that the consistency of
arithmetic with different sorts of means
and means that are actually things that
you guys might like better because they
use types and functionals between types
so what did the GTO do um and again it's
another one of the things he also had a
trailer or or a blog post uh in
1942 but he actually published it in
1958 uh this this um dialectica
interpretation and it's called
dialectica not because of anything to do
with hego or anything like that but just
because it was published in the journal
dialectica and his idea then was to um
was very I mean goo had lots of tricks
up his up his sleeves he had lots of
things that he could do that people
couldn't see why or how they worked so
the first for the thing that he did for
the dialectica was to say oh okay um
guys you only have to think about
constructive functionals because if
you're thinking about the classical ones
I did some interpretation of classical
logic in intuitionistic logic that will
solve that bit for you so we only need
to prove ha which is heing arithmetic
consistent and then he said okay the
other thing that we can do if you take
any form of hiding arithmetic whatsoever
so you know all sorts of interesting
functions there he said I can always
make it into a normal form that's very
strange because it's normal form is of
the shape that exist on new for all X
and then something that related to the a
but it is quantifier free so you know
you simplifying your life quite a bit by
taking things that are quantifier free
but putting a at the be at the beginning
a prenex one existential and one for
all and then he defined this translation
by by several claws recursively on the
connectives to unpack a formula whatever
formula you're given you just go
unpacking it to get to to the base case
where you know it's true so it's easy to
prove the term I mean easy H I'm I'm
lying here you know it's easy if you're
Professor trer or if you are one of
those guys you can prove uh that that
the the theorem that he wanted meaning
consistency of highing aritma Che but
it's very hard to see why it works and
and then that's where I get into the
picture because in
1988 long time ago I actually provided a
categorical model of G's dialectic
interpretation in my PhD
teis and okay I said I did not want to
to give you many symbols and that is the
only slide that has real mathematical
symbols so bear with me while we go over
it because what is happening here it's
actually very exciting and to my mind of
course and also very um
interesting so kind of historically
speaking because what you kind of want
to do is you want to kind
of you want to understand where the
dialectic uh interpretation comes from
so you want to kind of transform that
into structures and algebraic structures
of a kind of higher kind of stuff and
what you can do is you know you take the
the shape this thing should you take the
shape of the of the formulas that goo
plucked out of his inconscious the
existent new for all X Out Alpha of ux
or a of ux and you transform that into a
category which has objects
triples a type for U A type for x and
some sort of relation between the U and
the x that I'm calling Alpha of
ux so far so good you know you're just
saying okay if he managed to do this
translation and make everything becomes
of this shape then we can think about
that with this easy um categorical
structure But Here Comes the real
important and different PS because you
know when you kind of want to show that
one um formula in heing arithmetic
proves another formula so you have an A
of that shape there exists a u for X
Alpha of ux and then you have a you have
another one so a b of the shape for all
V there exists a V for all y beta of V
why and then look at that guys I mean do
you recognize the kind of funs of the
kind of functions that I'm kind of
giving you there I'm giving you an a
little F that takes U to V meaning I'm
mapping the existentials one existential
into the other
existential and that makes sense right
because you know if I want to prove an
implication I want to apply the
implication to Witnesses of the first
guy to get a witness of the second guy
but then then comes the big jump of GTO
which is to say it's not only that I
preserv the proofs of the things that
I'm I'm showing I actually preserve the
proofs but I actually map
back the counter examples I take a
counter example of the B and I send it
back to a counter example of the A and
you know you guys ReDiscover that right
because these are lenses they are just
what you think about when you're doing
lenses in functional programming and um
and that's something that goo kind of
came up with in
1958 that you know that lenses sort of M
morphisms transformations of lenses are
a very good way of
preserving uh truth of of formulas and
and actually kind of um
a way of crystallizing everything that
you need to know about this formal
system now the other bit of very
exciting news is that um instead of just
you know you think then that you start
from a a model of the simply type LDA
calculus a category C and you do this
construction and you think you'd get
another C Class another uh cartisian clo
category because you you think that you
start you're doing the things as um as
constructively as possible but you get a
model of linear logic instead of
constructive logic and that is kind of
very different so I now am kind of
getting up there so the point of this
dialectical categories or this
constructions is that as I was saying
guo proposed that in 1940 in 1958 he
actually published it uh in 1998 there
was this first C orical interpretation
in 2008 um people started generalizing
for different Logics and um first for uh
vibrations and kind of polymorphic types
then uh more modern versions of
vibrations and
2018 um Tamar VLAN and Sean Moss showed
that you could do that for dependent
type theories and very recently this
this year um with TR and spto we've been
showing that um that G's argument really
is um kind of universal in some ways
that is not just that you can construct
a model satisfying the things but
anything that satisfies uh the
properties that we want of a logical
system kind of ends up being um one of
these um GTO
vibrations so we have lots of
applications in CS so things like
concurrence Theory um linear function
programming partial compilers the lenses
that I just kind of described and even
automated differentiation is one of the
new things that we're doing so I I want
to close up here saying that yeah
changing models is very hard and it
takes a long time um I think that
despite all the good work of f wler we
still have
um the K being very under appreciated
and I think it's very important for
things like um strange Loop and papers
we love because it's it's very important
to have this kind of interdisciplinary
work between Math logic and programming
and I showed my example and maybe I
shouldn't refuse so much time on my
example but um but I think there are
plenty of other applications to develop
nowadays and I thank you very
[Applause]
much
I